[Music]
thanks to babel a language learning app
for sponsoring today's episode if you're
interested in growing your language
skills microcosmos viewers get up to 65
off with a 20-day money-back guarantee
when you sign up using our link in the
description
[Music]
at the bottom of the world is miles and
miles of desert
harsh winds blow over gravelly soil and
the lakes are covered in ice this is the
mcmurdo dry valleys 4 800 square
kilometers of polar desert situated in
the icy snowy continent of antarctica
it is surreal and majestic
and grand
but we are not journeying to antarctica
for the giant deserts and immense
landscapes we
are journeying to antarctica for this
we're being very generous to ourselves
with that we we is actually ariel
waldman explorer and president of the
san francisco microscopical society and
today she is our guest master of
microscopes because in 2018 ariel led a
five-week expedition to antarctica after
being awarded a grant from the national
science foundation's antarctic artists
and writers program and with additional
support from national geographic she
hopped on a plane to new zealand then
boarded a military transport aircraft
with 185 pounds a year to get to
mikbardu station her goal
to find and study microbes living in
antarctica
and not to spoil the mystery or anything
but she found them
on our journey to the microcosmos we
have met so many incredible organisms
that have evolved fascinating lives
lives that are lived in all sorts of
strange strange places there's been
ponds and tanks and beach sand but it's
one thing to imagine microbes being able
to survive anywhere it's another thing
to actually find an ostracod 74 feet
deep on the sea floor in antarctica one
of the most extreme climates in the
world
the organisms that live here are dealing
with frigid temperatures dark winters
wind and uv radiation so you have to
wonder
what survives it can't all be penguins
and seals
throughout the vast continent is an
array of tiny thriving creatures carving
out their own lives in the ice
and over the past few decades scientists
have been finding microbes in ice
exposed soils melt water ponds and other
pockets of antarctic geology with each
discovery scientists understand a little
bit more about how microbes are able to
survive in this harsh climate
moreover
the mcmurdo dry valleys are perhaps the
closest we come to replicating a martian
environment on earth making it a useful
area for astrobiologists to understand
the possibilities of life beyond our
planet
so with five weeks to search and explore
the continent ariel set out to find some
microbes of her own
but how exactly does one find microbes
in antarctica well any microbe hunt is a
function of the environment you are
hunting in and for our resident master
of microscopes james that means tubes
nets and careful monitoring of his
freshwater samples
for ariel it meant finding a way under
the sea ice
so she recruited the help of some divers
who gathered around a hole in the ice
and dove in
[Music]
and if you've ever wondered what it
looks like underneath an antarctic ice
sheet ariel ventured down a long metal
observation tube to watch the divers at
work and witness the hidden life under
the ice for herself after she brought
the samples back to her lab ariel used
the antarctic sea water available on tap
to keep them alive and happy as she
prepared to watch them under the
microscope but ariel didn't just rely on
divers she hiked through the mcmurdo dry
valleys and ventured to blood falls to
gather microbes living in the subglacial
iron oxide that spills out in bright red
colors across the frozen lake bonnie
she also hiked up to the top of a
glacier to find natural frozen over
holes on its surface
these are called cryoconite holes and
they form because of dark sediment
deposits that melt the ice around them
creating tiny ecosystems for wandering
microbes and across the surface of the
glacier are these little frozen-over
pockets of dirt and water that microbes
are quite happy to live in
so with some drills and a little help
ariel collected some dirt-filled ice
cores to study
under the microscope she found ciliates
and rotifers and tardigrades and
cyanobacteria
and what might be striking to you if
you've been following our journey for a
while is that these are microbes that we
have seen before and quite frequently in
some cases this might not be surprising
after all tardigrades are well known for
surviving seemingly unsurvivable
conditions but it is still so remarkable
to see a tardigrade in action to see its
legs wiggling and its body curling and
to know that it came from an icy pocket
inside an antarctic glacier
and then there are the diatoms those
single-celled algae encased in their own
glass shells we've seen their beautiful
jewel shapes before but these antarctic
varieties can sometimes reach such high
densities that their pigments stain the
sea ice brown
sea ice might seem like a strange place
for these photosynthetic organisms to
live but frozen sea water is full of
channels and pores creating little salty
corridors that house planktonic
creatures like diatoms that get trapped
in them as the surface water freezes the
ice then isn't just something that
freezes it is something that captures
and something that becomes home
and the microbes that live in these
homes whether in the ice or on the water
they all have stories to tell
in the beginning of the 20th century
captain robert falcon scott led the
discovery expedition through antarctica
and among the bits of antarctica the
expedition brought back were mats of
cyanobacteria collected from ponds of
melted water
these samples were carefully preserved
and stored in london's natural history
museum allowing scientists more than a
century later to study their composition
and compare them to the populations of
cyanobacteria that exist in antarctica
now
they found that the populations had
stayed roughly the same that the
cyanobacteria we see now are similar to
the cyanobacteria that existed back then
to some degree this is a kind of comfort
in an era where so much of our ecologies
are shifting but it may also be that the
time we have spent in antarctica is too
short and that the cyanobacteria's
future will look quite different from
its present
after all the cyanobacteria and other
microbes that are in antarctica now may
look similar to organisms we see outside
of the frozen continent but they are
still uniquely adapted to a very
particular and harsh way of life so the
consistency we see over the past century
may just be a function of the fact that
these organisms are so well suited to
their environment that new organisms
have difficulty finding their way in
but in a changing world those
well-carved niches may shift
changing the landscape and the life
within it
because antarctica for all its
appearance of a barren land of ice and
snow is not so barren after all it is
full of life found in different corners
and unusual pockets and life shifts and
changes but whatever these microbes tell
us of our world and our time or perhaps
even a distant world and a distant time
they are a reminder that even in deeply
unfamiliar lands
are deeply familiar friends
[Music]
thanks for coming on this journey with
us as we explore the unseen world that
surrounds us if you want to see more of
ariel's adventures and microbes you can
watch her antarctica video series on her
channel or you can visit
lifeundertheice.org
and before we go we also need to thank
babel for sponsoring this episode of
journey to the micro cosmos looking to
learn a new language in 2022 usually
trying to learn a new language requires
a lot of time and commitment making it
difficult to quickly get into
conversations well babel is a language
learning app that helps you use a new
language in real life situations after
only five hours of practice and it
offers lessons in 14 different languages
through short interactive 10-minute
lessons babel teaches more than just
vocab words it teaches you about the
culture people history and more
associated with the language you are
learning and babble offers multiple ways
to learn including podcasts games videos
and live classes so that you can choose
whatever format works for you
as a micro cosmos viewer you will get up
to 65 off with a 20-day money-back
guarantee when you sign up for babel
using the link in the description it's
really exciting to every once in a while
be able to bring you something special
here on journey to the micro cosmos and
i think that this episode is definitely
one of those we're so happy to be able
to collaborate with ariel on this and it
was all made possible by the people
whose names are on your screen right now
they are our patrons on patreon and we
are so grateful to them because we also
very much want this show to continue
existing
if you want to see more from our master
of microscopes james weiss you can check
out jam and germs on instagram and if
you want to see more from us
there's probably a subscribe button
somewhere nearby